he had a very moving piece posted on the
players Tribune just a couple of days
ago along with a video saying that his
brain he's going to donate it to CTE
research one day and hopefully that day
won't come for quite some time Warren
Sapp here on the Rich Eisen show with
Marshall Faulk how are you Warren what
up fellas good to chat with you what's
going on sad day ha know what I'm going
golfing today bleeder oh my god no come
on a second really want how how often do
you tee it up well everything that calls
me and tell me I have a beautiful
charity with a lovely golf course and a
place where I can go hack it up I'm
coming what well what's your handicap
I am Marshall don't let him don't let
him fool you I'm telling you Marshall AB
can play what's your handicap March
right what's your handicap Rachel what
he won't say it Warren you don't say
he's gonna fix it so what'd your mom say
yes I'll take it whatever this Rach
actually just don't to give out the
cannon oh here we go I'm a three
are you really 3.1 Wow yeah well I guess
I'd be it four years four years old when
I was with you you Aramis fix I have a
card is on my phone if you want me to
show you Warren that's by the way that's
a first
I have been working with mark how long
have we been working together what me
and Haley ERISA
okay we all played every 11 years you
got a question we just put it on the
table daddy there you go rich now you
know so why now how are you I guess is
the way to start the conversation today
out of time rich I'll be all day today
then one of the great sports center
people so didn't keep over and say that
they aren't we all yeah yeah mm-hmm why
did you write the piece where did this
either work i thing that sparkly was our
email from Fred Willis and it was a
email about you know the concussion suit
and everything that was going on and I
know that just by passing and don't even
worry about the lawyers handle that some
say can we read that email so I opened
the email up and it was our people in
full denial of that between the
correlation of hitting and head injuries
and I'm like like this can't be the line
that we're going with onto my
mom crab jerry jones all the progressive
homes that you know read books and you
know not not Neanderthals I couldn't
believe what I was reading so I began to
do research so that's what I did I want
to I want to find the information out
because I knew what they were saying in
that email that was being passed so
straight garbage I was straight god well
what now that wasn't something that I
was gonna subscribe to well they explain
to folks who Fred Willis is and what the
email Willis the old-school NFL player
that you know the email about the thing
and then I have to read you some of the
quotes in if you like rich you know
because I have to email with me did you
get this email - I got it
now I'm washing those little talk about
they went full big tobacco mold in this
email man it was crazy
who's the day the NFL or the owners or
who's the day in this email Marshall at
the you know to the the the they would
be whomever is going to shell out the
money yeah that's best ways your players
way to make lawsuit okay so I I mean I
don't want to say a owner and specific
but the day is the entity that's going
to have to pay for all right here's one
here's one for you reckon and this day
is the hair day there's a risk in life
there's a risk to sitting on your couch
or you mmm I don't know what risk on my
couch because I would have to let that
risk in my front door to the front desk
that has security so I don't know what
kind of couch he think I'm sitting on
you know my momma's couch back when I
was a dirt road in Plymouth that was a
little dangerous you know somebody might
want to come by and just you know cap
off one or two you know but I don't live
in that neighborhood number Warren Sapp
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
know a lot of what warrants and is it's
right but you know like the danger and I
think people don't understand the danger
is there's no way but in the detect and
a person that's alive yeah with CTE and
you know we're still trying to figure it
out there's science out there the good
thing is um there's some some medicines
that are out now that if you think you
have it take it you know like like hey
give it a shot don't don't wait until
symptoms hit you know don't wait to the
training that came through because
there's a lot at that point yeah Warren
are you I rent because I read your piece
and those who haven't please check it
out in the players Tribune you are
sometimes driving to a spot that that
you know like the back of your hand how
to get there and then I was going to see
my man double law and I go see double
all the time we have lunch all the time
great sandwiches lovely you know
pastries and all kind of foolishness
ground up with him all the time that's
my man so I'm going to see in this
Monday I mean I'm going in rich I just
turned around and it's on West Dixie I
mean it's just a north-south highway you
know just like the one I mean no side
highway and I just got to get down to
125th and go up now that I'm sitting
there talking to you now and I'm on like
135 on by you know Malou um spot there
Jim's captain Jim where I get my crunk
super and I just got and when I got to
Jim's I went blank like where am I going
and then I call Santana I'm like yo
we're double odds officer and he what
the laughing at me he was like come on
dawg you you double office like come on
man to tell me what double up and he
kept laughing at me so I got frustrated
with him I hung the phone of the turn
right we're home
cuz I mean it was just one of those
things doing like you know what I'm just
gonna go home get on my couch and I'll
be fine there he just wanted meant for
me to go to double Oz office today
that's what I you know just chopped it
up - but it wasn't that do you have
anything like that Marshall yeah not to
that extent rich it's a you know even
y'all have a car yeah I call back stuff
like that you start writing a texting
and like lesson in this I don't know if
everybody has that but you know it's
it's a and and in the football or not
you know the thing is we don't know and
we and a lot of players want answers and
Fred Willis is doing a great job at
passive information passing information
and trying to get guys to be a part of
the study and even even like as Warren
did
you know when you pass away your brain
is something that that will help I wish
them and I'm do they cannot my son you a
Tucson doc grandkids everybody did the
game we've know in love we must make it
better and why wouldn't we
here's something that I got for you much
we could do something that we never
could do when you alive will be in two
places at one time my bus gonna be in
Canton in my brain I'm being Boston how
about guys one side is a pillow beige
you always got a five-acre you know
because it's beautiful but we must lead
this game in better shape man when we
talk about 91 of 95 the first 95 brains
that they've got yeah I mean how am i
bed special to miss I know we first
ballot but was it like 80 of us now
Komodos getting bigger
yes and I'm just you know that there's
an end to Warren we'll talk after this
there's there's a there's medicines out
there now to help tonics with the brain
I got my horse way around its it some
have minds that you could I have my
market he'll trust I have my be true
right with me everywhere I go I do my
two sprays under the tongue every
morning and every night before I go to
bed yes I do
so what do you say to kids that are
coming into the league right now long
right what I say to parents is if
they're 13 and under there's no more
football that's what I do
we take away all that that years of
pounding and foolishness when we out
here living through the the coach that's
once his trophies is go show to his
friends at the office at the end of the
year he's nothing
you know I hate 19 year old championship
means anything as far as an NFL Draft
the part the part about that that
bothers me is I learned at a younger age
to play the game safe and smart how you
learn how to tackle the right way is a
shorter fall when you ten when you're
grown up along so if you're not
attacking you know not a play
but as you warned you said your brain is
not don't know I understand what he's
saying I might disagree with what he
said I'm saying learning how to play the
proper way well he sent it and there's
there's there's facts to that your brain
isn't is it ready for the for the
argument the bumpin and grindin it could
fall between 10 to 12 we got into South
I just I just worry about learning the
proper techniques you know it's like in
order to learn how to ride a bike at 5
and learn how to ride a bike at 15 you
look scared at 15 because you can go
faster the fall is harder that's all I'm
saying I agree what he is saying there's
no doubt about that
about this much um you shouldn't talk
you know they're teaching a new tackling
technique right oh yeah but right
what do you mean one particular new
tackling technique no more hand across
the brow riprap brow crossing and go
through it and and and i'ma you know
what uh Pete Pete Carroll they have a
system and how to tackle on hottest
night I never I've never seen it you
know I was gonna talk to Mike Bennett
buddy yeah Pete Pete Pete has done a
great job and listen they deliver blows
and you rarely come when they're guys
with a neck II with the neck problem or
a shoulder problem and they are teaching
a very proper way to tackle in the game
today well we know that the weekend
warriors that's out there with the 8 9
10 11 and 12 13 year olds ain't teaching
the proper technique a steel door
Oklahoma drill
they still do a building Marshall I no
doubt worn out warms a meal worn with
Marshall here in studio we wanted to
call you up and say way to go way to go
yeah okay man I'm just trying to get the
information out there because this is
something that will affect a lot of us
for a long time if we need to make this
game better because it's a beautiful
game it's nothing wrong with the game in
Russell not everybody is especially you
to be able to move into people like hey
I know okay I know I have to kind of
power perception of myself so I know who
would I'm figured about you don't an
admission you should have thought about
that when you pick me up and slam me you
should have thought about that house
you age it or thought about my
confession since your opening oh I'm
sorry
come on forget it come on stop hit him
straight today Warren apologizing um uh
I'll let her know
hit him straight one all the time all
the time you got love you
a man y'all go enjoy yourself I'm going
to go get me some balls write me some
nice wine and I might lose a couple
breaking sales that they put I'll be all
right Susie sitting in today to mourn
Susie my wife so Shannel lunch the
better half did not hello lovely I need
an invite to the beach that's all I just
want to hang out on the beach on the
deck and look out over the beautiful
view you're talking about the ocean
right there right work very much your
dick that's wrong take care one that's
taken that's Warren Sapp here in the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches